in your stand-up and in your whole
career in comedy
you've been a little obsessed with chain
food restaurants
and and you love to show them
the respect that you feel that they're
due
yeah it's kind of crazy to be known as
the comic that gives a lot of love to
chain restaurants
i know i can see it i mean i i
definitely
i have my favorites what do you love
what are the chain restaurants that you
really love
well i talk about chili's a lot because
i grew up i grew up going there there
you know they were the fancy restaurant
that you would go to after church on
sundays
uh so that's always a favorite hooters
is a big part of my life
uh you know can i ask you something i'm
being honest i i
never went to a hooters because i
thought i can't go to a hooters because
i i don't want people thinking i'm going
there to look at the ladies or whatever
but i've always been intrigued how's the
food at hooters
i mean i'm a fan i love the chicken
wings that's why i go i mean my whole
family actually
i was joking about my mom she's been
with us every trip
you take your mom to hooters yeah yes
she loved hooters and we would go
because you could get a ton of chicken
wings
and we had a big family and uh it was
like the perfect place to feed a bunch
of people and the food's really good
they
have tater tots um it's a dream come
true for us yeah where else are you
gonna get tater tots
fortune you act like you you act like
you found a golden doubloon
they have bags of them in the freezer
aisle
you had to go to an elementary school to
get tater tots before
hooters uh introduced them now they're
everywhere but i feel like they were
ahead of their time
what's your favorite thing on the
chili's menu if one thing you could have
triple dipper i mean that's it's an
appetizer but you get to choose three
things conan
and i'm talking about boneless buffalo
wings southwestern egg rolls and some
sliders
the fact that i know this is very
disturbing i love that that's an
appetizer too
that's i know let's start with what's
three things
let's let's start with these three
incredible foods also what's us would
you say a south
western egg roll oh yeah i didn't know
such a thing existed
that's i'm opening your world to a whole
new
way of living you know first of all
chili's has to love you because
you've got me talking about chili's now
and this is a basically a free ad
neither one of us is getting paid does
chili
chili's ever show you the love for all
you've done for them
i have to say they do show me a lot of
love they're like a
grandmother that sends things on like
holidays
i will get like a christmas sweater out
of the blue
look like chili's all over it or they
said candles
if there's like a if it's like a
president's day they send like
margaritas they're
pretty great and then after my netflix
special came out because i talked about
them on the netflix special they were
going to uh for my show in dallas where
the headquarters is they were gonna
um cater my green room with chili's
i felt like i had won an emmy it was the
greatest
of my life when they told me that that
actually sounds better than winning an
emmy i have to say
and and that means a sharp thing that
just gets in the way pretty quickly but
yeah
that sounds that sounds amazing it's
pretty great i wish that
all of a sudden we just had a triple
dipper come into frame right now but no
we are not getting paid for this
well once this goes out and airs i think
you and i are getting
uh you know what we want is i got ones
from arby's arby's gave me like a
special card
i can walk in and it it's like silver i
think i don't know why i think i
mentioned them on the show and they sent
me this card that i could
hold up and it gets me like a free roast
beef sandwich at arby's and the only
thing is i just felt i
i just felt like i can't use that
you know because i just felt bad about
going into an arby's and saying i'll
have this sandwich and
all right well uh there you go mr
o'brien oh and here's another thing not
gonna pay
this is on you buddy i wasn't gonna do
that that felt terrible
yeah i get that i get that because you
feel like you gotta at least
buy like some curly fries with it right
um
exactly yeah and then they gave me a
card for that so
um no you can't do it women in cards
lenny uh yeah i walk around my wallet is
just
filled with give me this for free fast
food cards
but you never use them no i don't use
them i know i should it's it's just
terrible but
i'm always thinking why did they give
this to me at the stage of my life where
i don't need it there was a whole stage
in my life
in my 20s uh where a fast food card
would have been very much appreciated
but now that's all the free stuff that's
celebrated right now
they can afford it now it's crazy